JIM THORPE
WAS A NATIVE-AMERICAN.
HE ENTERED
CARLISLE HIGH SCHOOL IN 1907.
HE WAS THE BEST
AT FOOTBALL.
THE BEST.
HIS COACH, POP WARNER,
WAS SAYING,
YOU KNOW, YOU COULD BE
AN OLYMPIAN,
AND SO HE STARTS REALIZING THAT,
AND HE'S LIKE,
I THINK I AM GONNA
WORK HARDER
THAN YOU'VE EVER SEEN
ANYONE WORK,
AND I'M GONNA BE
YOUR MOTHER[bleep].
SO HE STARTS TRAINING
FOR THIS NEW EVENT,
THE DECATHLON.
UH...
- SO HOW DID HE PREPARE?
- HOW DID WHO PREPARE?
- JIM THORPE.
- FOR THE OLYMPICS?
HE WOULD WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING
AND RUN 20 MILES,
TAKE A NAP,
EAT A MILD LUNCH,
AND THEN RUN
EVERY [bleep] EVENT
IN THE DECATHLON.
THAT IS CRAZY.
[chuckles]
THAT IS--
[chuckling]
THAT IS CR-AZY.
1912, SWEDEN, YOU KNOW,
STOCKHOLM, SWEDEN.
THIS IS THE OLYMPICS.
THIS IS--THIS IS
THE BEST OF THE WORLD.
THIS AVERY BRUNDAGE GUY, IS--
WAS THE FAVORITE.
HE WAS A WHITE GUY,
AND HE'S LIKE,
I'M GONNA BE THE MAN,
THE DUDE.
AND JIM THORPE WALKED IN
OUT OF NOWHERE.
PEOPLE WERE LIKE,
WHAT THE [bleep]?
LIKE, HOW IS HE THERE?
HE'S THERE,
AND AFTER THE FIRST DAY,
JIM THORPE
HAS THE POINT LEAD,
AND AVERY IS LIKE,
WHAT THE [bleep]?
WHO IS THIS GUY FROM?
WHO IS HE?
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THIS INDIAN IS IN THE LEAD.
AVERY BRUNDAGE
IS THE FAVORITE.
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN
IN THE PAPERS.
IT'S BEEN
IN--IN--IN EVERYTHING.
WELL, THE NEXT DAY, WE WAKE UP,
AND JIM THORPE WALKED IN,